komax ich muss ja auch sagen ja abgaben
absolut fit gemacht nicht noch zwei
clubs gemacht und ich habe vertrag
zunächst bekommen zu einem neuen video
leute ja vor kurzem bei luca gesehen der
den test darüber gemacht wie gute biegt
und ich dass mir dann so ja ok baby ist
jetzt eigentlich nicht so mein fall aber
ist eigentlich schon wichtig mal zu
überprüfen wie gut eigentlich das eigene
wissen über die youtuber ist über die
man immer so redet deswegen leute machen
wir heute ein test darüber wie gut ich
apo-med kenne und glaubt mir die texte
teilweise richtig richtig geil
formulieren lukas test der bestrafung ja
jetzt durchziehen oberlenningen mit der
polizei nehmerqualitäten mit rabatten
mit da ich war nicht mehr herr bach
mister 4000 euro paket das eine fünf
getroffen
letzteres ist nur ein sneaker schnüffeln
der leermasse stricher oder ein
unverstandener boden so geniale rossini
der moderne
statt dessen genie erste frage upgrade
benutzt klick versuch alles klar
dankeschön gut dann muss ja auch mal rat
leute ich weiß nicht ich will einfach
mal sagen war keine ahnung was er ist
eine gefahr glaubt der siamesische
zwillinge war alter so was von war
kabarettist mit dem prinzip der
schmelzende schokolade vertraut ein
stück käse diktiert
[Musik]
ich weiß es nicht etwa die wir so noch
eine möglichkeit mit dem wir müssen
jetzt einfach raten par rapport ein
stück käse identifizieren
ehrlich gesagt nicht apa red weiß dass
nicht jeder tag ein sonntag ist nein das
heißt ja nicht auf gar keinen fall bei
seiner parade reagiert allergisch auf
unsichtbaren rasierklinge schon wieder
mit raus hin ob ein geniales juni der
moderne ist ewa ich weiß gar nicht ob er
etwas ist das ja eher reagiert
allergisch auch nicht beglichen apparat
ist eigentum der züchter oder youtube
sklave das ist favorit fliegt öfter mal
seine schuhe könnt ihr euch deutschland
das upgrade zu hause sitzt mit nur dann
erlaubt eine besonders unrühmliche auch
star trek ist ein mann des abend volk
von verzichten sein videos auf sämtliche
gegenstände die in abgehoben wirken
lassen können aber wagen 4000 euro
fashion paket lambo r8 auf jeden fall
werden der bodenständige werte mannes am
volkes prozentwert die auswertung leute
alarmstufe rot die haben sieben von zehn
aufgaben richtig beantwortete steht bei
592 leute weil ich kann meinen eltern
nahmen auch unter die augen treten wenn
ich allein
[Musik]
welche was leute wie wir schon die
tränen weg denn es gibt noch eine zweite
chance
sein wissen über abholt unter beweis zu
stellen ein echter apa red
dann zeigt es mit diesem geld das geht
in eine ganz andere richtung leute das
wär mal richtiges wissen was ist das da
am rand alter ich habe den fucking
adblocker an warm cremig eine anzeige wo
steht everything is better with bacon
ist ein fucking hähnchenschenkel in
einem menschen das ideale auto für
vorstellungsgespräche mit upgrade mit
richtigem namen der richtige name
spricht da wenn mich nicht alles täuscht
nadine und nicht nach ihm
oder halt einfach bruno dienen meinte
deswegen geht man hier auf nachdem wie
viele abos hat apa/red stand 30
vertreter 2015 bis 600.000 666 die
thailänder ta presse ein schöner
angefangen und es gab keinen plan wie
viele aufrufe hat apa/red stand 30
erneuter 2015 wo er durch das wissen
wann hat er sein erstes tattoo live
video hochgeladen
ich habe wieder keinen plan leute ich
bin mir richtig schlechter ab als verein
bitte dass leute wie ist es anfangs red
video deutschland wie viele bz apropos
positiv bewertet
diese fragen kann doch nur der youtuber
geräte richtig beantworten wie
chatroulette videos upgrade auf seinem
kanal abgerundet durch chinesen boden in
afghanistan
abgerundete viele leute apparat
abonniert sollte ich mich eher ich hab
keine angst jetzt direkt betrifft ist
das video auf youtube geklickt hat das
aufgeräumte für 200 euro tippen zeigen
auf jeden fall eine von zehn aufgaben
richtig beantwortet 196 ist der
durchschnitt schlechter schnitt leute
baumax ich muss ja auch sagen ja abgaben
abriss gemacht wenn nicht noch ein
und ich hab' verkackt ich war schlechter
als der durchschnitt bei mir wurde
gesagt mehr ab ich hätte da nicht
gebrauchen können
geburtstag aber leute ist hat doch ganz
positives dass ich noch in die uni geht
da kann ich noch eine andere sache über
apa/red lernen und dann vielleicht beim
nächsten mal bitte mehr davon zehn
praktische aufgaben richtig beantworten
viele leute bei diesem kind über mein
großes idol wirklich gefallen könnt ihr
haben den kanal abonnentenzuwachs alles
wieder offen
nicht mal war leicht leute und chat